avec ces vestiges de l'antiquité ses
plages ses montagnes la tunisie attire
en temps normal des touristes de partout
une sorte de havre de paix quand on la
compare aux pays voisins du maghreb
c'est pourtant ici qu'est né le
printemps arabe
dans le centre et le sud du pays loin
des plages et des grands hôtels
la colère couve encore aujourd'hui à
queyroi par exemple une ville de plus en
plus d'habitants la région la plus
pauvre de tunisie et celle qui affiche
le plus haut taux de suicide au pays
fatiha vie avec ses quatre enfants dans
la maison de sa belle famille sans
travail sans revenu sans mari et un
traitement par son mari travaillait
comme gardien pour une entreprise d'état
il touchait un maigre 200 dollars par
mois à peine de quoi payer l'épicerie et
après dix ans au l'a congédié il n'a pas
supporté cette idée comme dark l'autre a
démarré sa valeur l'essence châle rouge
et amour à 10 et les manades fatiha
raconte que ses deux plus jeunes ont vu
leur père père de conscience le corps
calciné par terre incapable de leur
parler c'était en novembre dernier
et ouais tu voulais me sera notre
dernier
[Musique]
on
admet les pas de la virade mais pas du
tout m vidéo dans la famille
[Musique]
saoussen fadil directrice régionale
d'une ong qui a réalisé une étude sur le
suicide et la pauvreté en tunisie
son groupe a recensé près de 300 cas en
dont plusieurs dizaines à kairouan
seulement pour elle
le constat est alarmant quand on peut
constater une augmentation des cas de
suicide après la révolution
généralement ce sont les hommes qui font
beaucoup plus de tentatives de suicide
que les femmes
il faut dire aussi que ça a touché aussi
les enfants et il a accroché les
personnes âgées tous
on est là pour défendre une cause
légitime surtout des lois du travail du
travail le travail il y à une mauvaise
gouvernance les milliers de diplômés des
chercheurs détenteurs de doctorat
tiennent régulièrement des
manifestations pour réclamer des emplois
c'est le cas de djamel et bluesy docteur
en biologie qui souhaite créer son
laboratoire il n'y a pas cet esprit pour
les l'industrie tunisienne aussi pour
avancer pour aussi pour augmenter la
compétitivité entre l'industrie
tunisienne et l'industrie internationale
et donc n'est pas cet esprit en fait
d'embaucher les docteurs comme des
milliers d'autres tunisiens ils se
voient forcés à l'exil
il espère s'établir au canada où il
était invité comme chercheur les
docteurs je pense que sont en état de
dépression en tunisie
[Musique]
ce député tunisien constate que la
tunisie s'est appauvrie depuis la
révolution
faut dire aussi qu'il y avait une
certaine collusion entre le pouvoir
politique et les acteurs économiques au
les lobbys économiques du temps de ben
ali
et malheureusement ça a continué après
la révolution
le pib a fortement chuté le chômage a
augmenté il est à plus de 16%
deux tiers des dépenses de l'état
servent à payer les salaires des
fonctionnaires
ce modèle est fini il a réalisé ses
objectifs et on devrait passer un autre
modèle économique qui crée de la
richesse qui créent de la valeur ajoutée
et qui soit en phase avec ce qui ce
passe dans le monde
l'ouverture politique et la tenue
d'élections libres qui est la liberté
d'expression sont les grands acquis de
la révolution tunisienne
mais de nombreux militants blogueurs et
journalistes qui critiquent le
gouvernement ou la police sont encore
arrêtés interrogés parfois emprisonnés
[Musique]
voilà imed ben coude a été arrêté pour
avoir publié sur facebook une caricature
qui se moque de la police une façon
amusante pensait-il de protester contre
la violence policière
des policiers en forme des chiens avec
des matraques
c'est une caricature cet activiste a été
harcelée au téléphone par des policiers
puis convoqué par un procureur accusé de
porter atteinte à l'image de la
république est détenu et interrogé
pendant sept heures par la police
il a finalement été libéré de
l'intimidation pure et simple ce rugby
c'est un combat très lent pour avoir
regroupé dit vraiment à 100%
démocratique on doive voir un peu du
temps c'est pas aujourd'hui on peut on
va dire que la tunisie et démocratique
cet avocat représente des blogueurs
activistes qui purgent des peines de
prison allant de quelques mois à
quelques années le matin de notre
rencontre devant un tribunal
étroitement gardés par des policiers il
allait plaider pour la libération du
militant annie ce mâle roux qui bien
connu pour ses coups de gueule contre le
régime mabrouki a été arrêtée deux
semaines de plus tôt pour avoir appuyé
une dame âgée qui manifestaient pour
faire valoir son droit au logement
son avocat croyait faire libérer
aisément son client accusé d' outrage à
une personne publique mais presque à
nessma bros qui a été libéré non à nice
en bouquets des prisons donc on
attendait maintenant le jugement
la décision rendue en fin de journée
n'est pas du tout celle attendue
le blog écope d'une peine de quatre mois
et demi de prison
comme la majorité des blogueurs il a été
victime de ses opinions
on va combattre pour ce cela qui nous
reste qu ils ont les factions de
continuer ce massacre
ces poursuites judiciaires c'est le
moment de revoir ses lois de réformer
ces lois des lois issues de la dictature
qui n'ont toujours pas été modifié à
cause de nombreux blocages ou parlement
tunisien
il n'y a pas de volonté politique
vraiment de faire une réforme en
profondeur
parce que bien sûr c'est ça qu'on vient
pour le monde un de garder ce genre de
de loi
il ya de plus en plus de mécontentement
et donc il y aura de plus en plus d'
expression de mécontentement sur
facebook qui peuvent déranger les
décideurs politiques
on n'a pas l'impression qui va y avoir
une évolution positive dans l'avenir
sans une prospérité économique social on
pourra pas soutenir la démocratie
le tunisien il a besoin de manger
d'éduquer ses enfants d'accéder à la
santé c'est ça des revendications
d'utiliser en maintenant m
[Musique]
depuis le suicide de son mari fatiha al
ahly n'a touché aucune indemnité pas
même le salaire qui lui était dû elle
souhaite trouver un jour le moyen de
terminer la construction de leurs
maisons laissées en chantier par son
mari pour elle et ses quatre enfants
[Musique]
dix ans après son déclenchement la
révolution tunisienne demeure fragile et
les rêves qu'elle a suscité encore
inaccessibles
[Musique]